alter aber mit dem turbo ich bin nicht
so schnell hier mit unglaublich erhält
kommt gerade so viele wallonie auf den
server 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 12
leute sind gerade abends waren alle
nehmen getrennt voneinander auf hallo
ich meine lieben freund und herzlich
willkommen zurück bei minecraft hero
immer noch zusammen mit cash und auf dem
server sind außerdem noch bombay sind
viel zu voll acht leute um einen alle
nehmen ihnen die sonntagabends um 8 uhr
immer auf wie man gerade so etwas nicht
mehr machen möchte in dieser folge ist
eine trial rüstung zumindest ein
bisschen davon und zwar erstmal das
chippis in einem mexikaner diamanten
erst mal wirkt er in alter so eine
kartoffel
ok ich weiß nicht ich weitermachen soll
deswegen mache ich einfach irgendwie
weiter das konzept eigentlich so erst
mal ganz gut
extertal diamanten habe ich drei leder
brauche ich noch verbessern muss man
dahin alle zuschauer weiß nicht wie ich
das zu machen soll
luca ja da warte ich konnte ford vorbei
ich heiße wir dann mal ein bisschen weil
diese schräge die ich echt und echt
kacke gelöst also das wird episch
aussehen aber nicht in diesem leben juhu
ich habe eine privatschule
ich mache mal so ein match das passt
perfekt mir habe ich gerade zum sound im
hintergrund an also hinter der musik
gehört jemand auf natur und du hast du
auch gut gemacht und die haben diesen
politiken blasen
das ist der wasserstoff da sind die
vorteile sind ja gut
was soll ich dir helfen wer wo was euch
was soll ich dir helfen gehen hier
hinten und zwar weiß nicht wie ich hier
ist die verbindung klar also ich mach
das erstmal so also einmal als solo aber
wie mache ich das da in diesem
zwischenbereich hier ist einmal ein
abgeschlossener kasten
und hier ist ein abgeschlossener kasten
das ist aber nur komische kurve hier du
ja irgendwie schon ging's symmetrisch
gibt man geht man allerdings ein
bisschen red wird
okay man könnte das ja auf jeden fall
muss er so was mal die grundbasis sein
auf der anderen seite eigentlich auch
nur das muss ja so sein will ich sagen
gebt mir noch diese anderen steinchen
die du hast diese diese dauern die wir
da oben
wieso ich möchte etwas gucken was dich
nämlich schon viele hier und hier
das mag mit station drauf köpfe ist
sieht man gleiches gipfel wohl endlich
ich weiß gar nicht was man das passt
halt nur als schwejk genau zu dieser
ecke hier gegner eigentlich das ganze
konzept von diesen dingen muss gar nicht
sein wenn ich ein jetpack jetzt sowie im
4 dies teilte das natürlich kannst du so
oder was glaube ich dir fliegen könnte
man das mal ist falsch oder diese diese
schuhe die muss mir auch noch machen
er ist diese schule mit dem man zwei
hoch springen können aber wenn ich hier
und ich das doch gar nicht machen weil
das ding ist das ist ja immer ein
darunter
jetzt müsst ihr auch rein theoretisch so
sein hätte ich kann die gar keine sachen
jedem wegen sind magneten zurück zurück
gelaufen und mir das geben was sie
selber das will kann ja nie hätte ich
tun
also ich kann das nicht geben man immer
mein helm setzen erst mal ich glaube ich
so etwas doch ab weil das ist mir ganze
zeit schon ein dorn im auge
so passt dass ihr davon so ist das haus
stimmig an sich kann einfach so ein ja
stimmt aber ich kriege keine kurve in
das ist ganz komisch
das heißt weil das ja immer breiter ist
ne ich überlege auch gerade also erstmal
muss sowieso so hin
könnt ihr das blaue chocobo was frei
rumläuft mähne war glaube ich mache
jetzt bisschen an die sbb
so geht das sieht erstmal nicht schlecht
aus weil das hier muss nicht sein dass
hier online manuel sieht mich rum
so ist der durchsetzen sie weiter kriegt
und wer böse ist wird bestraft junge ich
konnte nicht raus ich konnte nicht raus
man fordern ich schwöre manuell noch
einmal dass ich hier gefällt mir das
doch nicht so ganz weil ich will dass
man es sieht ich will dass man hier
sieht das vorhaben muss ich meinen job
mein garten drin oder age ii panschow
comedian der in der links in der halle
ist war er okay sie meinen garten oder
gar nicht doch da steht das hawkeye so
was sollte ich denn jetzt machen so die
rüstung habe ich daher ich wollte
verzaubern gehen und dafür brauche ich
erfahrung
deswegen wollte ich an eine höhle gehen
wofür ich das mal stirbt wolf kabul
abgeschossen als er mich gezogen hatte
wie das sagt nächstes mal führte ihn ja
das habe ich auch gesagt guck mal
erzählt nicht aus ich bin ihr gab am
baum wie geil ist das denn verfolgte
hatte ich auch die gleichen sachen wie
er aber ich gehe jetzt produktiv sein
ich stehe hinter manuel so eilig dass
jeder einzelne ein bisschen aufnimmt ich
gehe jetzt in irgendeiner höhle und
versucht mir irgendwo gold abzugreifen
ich gehe mit schoko aber es geht gleich
wieder nacht wird ja egal da mich ja in
einer höhle und schreiber mal im hass
dazu weil ich dann ja schon einfach in
mein kind dann kannst du dir wissen was
nehmen oder glas gleich ja glas habe ich
auch 40 habe ich alles habe ja klar wenn
du mir bei dem zauberstab da hilft bei
diesem fall klar jetzt schon sagen
bewusst eine medical ist es ein
elektriker sense ein stick und moral was
was was einstiges klar und ein diamant
das wort also magic und diamant
electricals gemeint dass auch selber
keine electrical oder na ja aber ich
habe mein tipp du brennst marvin alter
ich laufe mit dem weißen chocobo echt
echt hier berge hoch wie unter sechs
grad echt ich laufen oder mit dem geld
was ja ich bin grad marble tipps
spitzhacke
aus den so ein bisschen kohle alter aber
mit dem turbo ich bin echt so schnell
hier mit unglaublich viel geld kommt
gerade so viele mal um die auf dem
server 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 12
leute sind gerade abenteurer und alle
neben getrennt voneinander auf nahezu
sicher ist dass krank es ist einfach
full house hier unnormal jetzt im krieg
das ist eigentlich die optimale
situation krieg zu führen direkt jetzt
krieg und normal so er hierhin ist das
mpc doch wo wir schon einmal waren
und da man leute zu mir dass dahinter
eine kleine existenz sei diesen übels
häufig aber da geht die sind nicht so
hoffe ich habe mich dass man jetzt noch
glaubwürdig sagen ja aber ich bin ihr
den weg gelaufen dann weil ich jetzt
zufällig gerade da so ich weiß ja nicht
ob mir das schön finde was ich ihr bau
atomarer erst schlag wir haben heimlich
waffen haben heimlich waffen monz
installiert ist er auch sagte heldt es
ist witzig wenn man mit ganz vielen
leuten hier ist übrigens leute nicht
jede von diesen komischen blauen blumen
des gleich nächste call ist es gibt auch
andere offizielle diese aussehen wie so
ein ball flieger ball
ich habe ganz so ein bisschen angst
jetzt wenn das hier so krass nachtisch
ist nachts schon aber du kannst wie du
nicht schlafen also ja aber da wäre ich
lieber in der stadt bei euch allen
als jetzt hier allein unterwegs da
stimmt gitter muss ich mir noch machen
ich glaube ich werde mir so eine kleine
vorrichtung war das eisen türen habe und
man bestimmten schalter irgendwann
schlagen muss damit er aufgeht nein ich
hab dich dann stoppe nicht gesehen
den und ich freuen uns immer vorbei
sternschnuppen aber allem einen total
doof und wenn
wir entwickeln und spinnen und doofe
leute halt da irgendwer irgendwas ab
online hier sind pinguine und bei mir
hat es gerade ein wenig wer ist das
nächste doktor hat gefightet
ich sehe wie uns die käuflichen
gegenseitig gehörte harry wir uns immer
sexy callahans leute sagt ich mache
jetzt mal ein vergleich freunde damit
ich wieder tausend sachen den
kommentaren spam fernen mexiko sands
keine hexe kiel aus ich weiß nicht was
die blüte hier bringt die kann ich auch
irgendwie nicht abbauen
achtung statt rot was sind wir keiner
von den ist gratis statt roter karte
weil sie malt ist ja bei uns was machen
wieder so dann gehe ich jetzt mal ein
bisschen rum hier sind ganz ganz viele
blaue blumen ok alles klar wir lassen
uns nicht beirren wir machen hier weiter
lockern
ja ja klar ich mache ja du dich selber
sei etwa so ich bin hier mit meinem
trikot unterwegs und ich geh jetz auch
gerade eine höhle rein gerückt und ich
hoffe mal dass ich und jetzt ein
bisschen ja man da schon mal ein
bisschen gold weil ich möchte mir
endlich diese schuhe machen mit denen
ich keinen fall schaden bekommen und
dafür brauche ich eine menge gold auf
jeden fall aber hier ist auch eine menge
kohle scheißegal ist ohne make-up mega
spinne mega spinne ultras spinne das
heißt ein mega spinne steam die größe
oder seine ultras pinnacle und baulich
schlucht ist es da unten ich traue mich
auch nicht als runter zu gehen weil ich
will euch nicht stattfinden
was das denn was auch das hier
das ist konzentriert essenz barry weißt
du dass es ganz kurz
rede mit mir was er verlinkt
concentrating sainsbury keine ahnung
habe ich dir gesagt so ich geh jetzt
weiter zudem denken mit meinem schoko
bertrand ich habe nämlich das von ihm
geleitet aber ich hab nichts geleitet
weil bei katzen inventar mit baumaterial
voll ist und alles mögliche wegwerfen
musste deswegen kann ich es gar nicht
gesammelt haben jetzt auch ehrlich
gesagt nicht so bock auf einer
höhlentour gegen kann man eigentlich
immer viel zu treffen und zu machen
ja ich glaube schon ich habe eigentlich
alles überhaupt ne den marvel brig wenn
überhaupt eher marvel bringt viel zu
viel scheiße im inventar mann mann mann
alter
ich gucke die ganze die ganzen blumen an
und war erwartet dass die irgendwie eine
hexe diesmal noch mal kommt weil ich
gehöre hier geht's einfach erkennen da
ja aber uns beim paar treppchen und
freuen uns im keks ich weiß gar nicht ob
die triebe scaler oder diese scale armor
free baglama das game welche da besser
ist die baglama wurde mir geschrieben
dass die eigentlich schlechter sei aber
von den fähigkeiten her wohl besser also
dass man damit irgendwie produktiv mehr
anfangen könnte technisch also das
macbook sagen das sind so wirklich
insiderinformation das streiten ich
glaube ich auf geister wo sie sagen auch
kaum das finde ich jetzt besser das
nicht gibt so viele verschiedene
optionen
ja das stimmt auch wieder obwohl sie ist
mein job und immer dahin wo ich im kopf
da nein daran dass
da oben ist auch keine taktik ist auch
kein sexy kulissen
das werfe ich habe dass etwas im
internet
mit diesem wasser geräusch auf sich wir
könnten theoretisch da hinten einfach
mal der burg rheinstein das ist glaube
ich geil aus hier echt heftig wie
einfach alle am thema vorbei quatschen
also wir beide erhalten bleibt weil wir
verschiedene sachen machen das natürlich
komplett haben wir sind halt schön
konzentriert ich denke dass nämlich gar
nicht so schlecht ehrlich gesagt ja ich
denke ich noch nicht
so sagt jan die ecken würde ich sagen
marble kabels darunter dann sieht das
ein bisschen besser aus von außen sah
das fundament geht hier bis nach ganz
unten
wir haben ja auch schon mal die zeit
gibt so schnell rum wenn so viele da
sind
fangen wir mal das gefühl dass ich liebe
zum produkt titel in dieser zeit weiß
bauten sind diamanten aber ich traue mir
nicht da hinzugehen weil da so viel
durch leuten von denen wie verbinde ich
jetzt hier das ist die frage
doch aber das müsste ich eigentlich
schaffen darf mich jetzt hier so ein
wenig grob mich hier so einen weg
diamanten diamanten auftaktwoche helle
falls ich habe kaum hell soll ich hab
alles du kannst du bei mir fast nehmen
wenn du was ich habe jetzt wirklich nur
sieben ich hoffe das reicht wenn nicht
dann komme ich bei dir ja ja klar dass
noch kein helles von mir nehmen
das habe ich doch hier ausgebreitet so
zog ich würd sagen ich gar nichts mehr
tokio wir begeben uns mal zurück auf den
rückweg aber pinkett holz für jede
sammeln finke ist ja genau wir haben
gefunden brauche helles holz das eine
komische gelbe blume mit blumen gelbe
blumen die leuchtet nur damit die
leuchte ich glaube das sagen natürlich
fackel so holz holz holz auf checa so
ist auch das dunkle dann habe ich rotes
holz benutze mein haus nicht ich hab das
falsche holz in meiner art rechts und
ich hab aus trotz bei der gelben blume
das ist eine nacht blume die geht nur
bei nacht an
wie kann ich meine mein fuß heilen
das ist ein bisschen mehr leben kriegt
dieser ach ja stimmt ich einfach zu
fressen geben
diese fristen geben oftmals so hier
sagten fast nie sagt das ist doch ganz
geil aus jetzt einfach mal intuitiv
zurück nach hause ohne die koordinaten
zu benutzen da klingt richtigen weg ich
glaube ich muss irgendwie das vielleicht
noch links im ohr das kriegt immer
schaden bin echt gespannt wie ich das
hier hinkriegt weil ich weiß nicht ob
das ergebnis der eingang muss natürlich
offen sein
das sozusagen die waffenkammer und ist
haltlos schnell rein laufen können leute
schreibt man bissigen kommentare was das
was mir diese dieser pilz da bringt ich
kann ja nicht mehr abbauen
das ist ja irgendwie total komisch der
wechsel nur bei mais oder in diesem
alter was ballack der die ganze zeit
jahren nichts zu tun
nur am plaudern uhr am ende ich glaube
ich erst mal geil aus muss man aber
sagen ich bin doch nicht den weg nach
hause
doch mit dieser komischen wurf bei der
ich werde wach wie tun wo bin ich
mexikos erwarte ich weiß nicht was für
ein heute sich baumann kurz das ist auch
dieses holz hier
dieses holte was wenn holz ist das knapp
fünf hektar lizenzen auf diesem weg sehr
stolz auf mich
das ist es nicht doch ich weiß wo wir
sind
diese blumen könnte ich noch mal mit ihm
diese nämlich ganze nun eigentlich die
stelle ich mir einfach mit so einem
blumenbeet bei mir voraus
da leuchten nur über nacht und dann
spiele ich hab mir ohne witz das falsche
holz mein gesamtes haus verwendet als ob
doch also fast was falsch ist heute aber
das ist ein anderes holz dass sie so
ähnlich auch das ist verrückt und mich
auch gut das sieht so ähnlich aussah
preisvergleicher dass er so ein
komisches holz das ist so leicht im ton
matton schnelle axa alter erhalten
was hatte ich muss mich eben davon
überzeugen ob es das ist was ich denke
all das noch eine kahle sind etwa so
geht das nämlich auch klar so macht das
war echt billig wenn es das ist was ich
denke so machen ob mein gott ich habe
eine giraffe gefunden was hat sagt das
ist eine giraffe geil ist das denn die
will ich haben könnt ihr euch nicht
paaren tokio und giraffe was wäre das
für eine mischung die waffe mit schoko
womit du abbauen kannst aber so bäume
von oben oder sex mit denen und bonbons
machen gegen ihn irgendwie profil kann
ist so aufmachen so sagt das sollte
reichen nicht die nicht irgendwie hier
beliebe mitmachen wenn ich darf dann
muss ich die stark die waffe auf die
wirklich fertig
aber ja paar sachen gedruckt schöner
durchgang und hier sozusagen von uns aus
rein kann auch von der anderen seite aus
nicht wenn ich bin ja der waffenmeister
ich möchte erstmal noch nach hause
kommen jetzt irgendwie in der folge
deswegen ziehe ich jetzt gleich mal ein
bisschen obwohl vielleicht schaffe ich
sogar noch ich mal nur noch kurz ein
schildchen dann bin ich auch tue hier
noch ganz kurz die koordinaten sagen wo
du gerade bist - 4000 - audi tv sender -
4200 - 4200 1500 das 1500 okay aber hier
ist auch seine statue die wir in der
stadt haben ich dachte wir hätten die
selber gebaut wo ich bin schon wieder
eine stadt jedoch nicht ist doch nicht
unsere statistik arbeiter eingang f er
steht einfach nur ein hobby aber hier
waren schon mal hier dann lese meine
hunde irgendwoher drohen mitarbeiter
wenn irgendwo existenzen drei bewerbe
ruhig wenn ich die vergessen haben
jakobus vielleicht mal wieder füttern
also ein schock war als
fortbewegungsmittel ist schon mal was ja
ich glaub ich kann mir sogar schon fast
eine komplette exil rüstung machen so
viele wie ich gefunden habe habe nämlich
acht gefunden auf diesem kleinen weg es
hört sich nicht schlecht an das schon
kannst so da ist es besser dass dieser
komische tempel den wir gesehen haben
ja ja aber ich gehe als nicht rein hilfe
noch ein bisschen zu heftig so sagen
übrigens leute dass ich gerade ein
bisschen überziehen aber ich möchte
lieber nach hause findet statt dann
wieder hier sein du willst schild zu
setzen um dann zu sagen ich muss das
jetzt auch ausgeleuchtet das läuft
wunderbar sieht sehr gut aus
und da wird ja was sagen hier gesagt
waffenmeister ohne ihren war ein paar
scheiben das müssen wir noch fertig
machen aber ansonsten sieht das doch
schonmal sehr sehr gut aus wir haben
ordentlich was geschafft vor allem hat
war den durchgang von un- ziel geschafft
von unserer hütte auch durch den man nur
noch von dieser seite aus betreten kann
damit fällt die kisten auffüllen können
ja und ich bin gleich zu hause das geht
so mega schnell mit meinem job ohne also
es hat nur noch zehn von 40 leben aber
ich werde das kommando irgendwo immer
unter jockey was laberst du bist unser
staat aber ich bin da kann ich dir
gleich erzähle ihr zuhause
ich begrüße mich begrüßt mich also da
noch die pfeile reinpacken jetzt eben
meine kiste denn und ist alles wieder
perfekt aber ich ein bisschen in folge
bleibt konstant starken partner ganz
schnell in togo war das ist echt die
größte folge welche zu überziehen musste
mich möchte die sache neben integrierten
in die kisten packen obwohl er kommt
dass man beim nächsten mal einfach
wissen für nächstes jahr wieder leicht
gefallen da will ich mir von diesem jahr
ein zunächst mal was gutes